[Music]
okay everybody so this is my spoiler
review of the newest batman film
the batman now disclaimer i am not a
person who's restored the snyder verse
i'm not this big zack snyder fan
i'm not also someone who's holding it to
the
heights of a dark knight let's say with
christopher nolan but
i look at every film i review just with
a clear slate in mind no bias going in
and
you know i had a lot of mixed feelings
about this film so
what's tricky is
you see it comes out to a really high on
tomato score that really hypes it up for
everybody and then you get your
expectations really high so then when i
said to myself like okay lower
expectations just go into this watching
it as a movie and what i did to prepare
was i watched all of matt reeves
filmography before this everything he's
directed before this film and he still
falls in a lot of traps that frustrate
me about him as a director and that
happens in this film too where if you've
seen
the recent film he did the war of the
planet of the apes and dawn of the
planet of the apes
he plods along like i feel like he
doesn't have a good sense of pace i feel
like he's another director gets two in
his own head where he probably loves
every scene so much which is great of
course that's what you want to do when
you're filming right but
where is the feeling of this is slowing
down too much or this needs to pick up
like i don't feel that he had that in
mind making this film which was
frustrating because
let's compare it to the biggest 10-pole
film that also came out recently which
is spider-man away home right both
very similar run times and the key
difference here was with spider-man on
my home i'm literally engaged from the
start and it didn't let go of me that
whole time and it felt like an hour film
watching it and i felt so many emotions
from it none of that happened here and i
was expecting that i was expecting to be
on the edge of my seat engaged
especially if it's such a long run time
you have to justify it it's got to be
even more
bringing you in and aware of its pacing
and that's where the editing falters for
me too that there needed to be some
stuff cut out here you look at spiderman
at home i hate to keep comparing it to
it but i am because it's another big
super bowl temple movie that's a long
run time and
that film had
from the audience i was in about 10
moments where people clapped this film
had about two and that happened when
batman jumped off the building and flew
with the bat suit and when we first see
the batmobile those are the moments but
that was it for my audience at least and
i was a packed house so that was
disappointing
as well
but i didn't not like the film i think
it's a very good film but it's not great
it feels like it's holding back it feels
reserved and it never really takes off
so
let's talk about the villain here the
main villain in the riddler now
paul dano is one of my favorite actors
my favorite performance by him was there
will be blood so i knew he'd kill it as
a ruler he always brings it and he did
not disappoint here he was amazing i
thought he was the best performance of
the film clearly and it was the most
dynamic performance however i'm
frustrated what they do with the riddler
because when we compare it now to the
most popular portrayal of a villain in
the batman films with heath ledger's
joker it's like it took from the dark
knight the scenes where the joker would
threaten batman through the video calls
right
and we never got that really escalated
to more with the riddler until later on
yeah he gets captured and he has his
moments with batman there but it should
have been more way earlier where you saw
the dark knight they had like okay a
couple video messages from the joker and
then he shows up at the dining room and
we have this big moment where they're
face to face where with the riddler here
i felt like it was like all zoom calls
here you know
why was it so many of them and i i know
it's hard to pull it off because he's
got to do the riddles it's the chase
right but
he didn't have his epic moment in person
which was frustrating to me
and i think you need that for a film
like this especially with it this long
like you're kind of waiting like can we
see him now like how many of these are
just going to be video calls like
you know this is like did they just film
all his scenes in one day with an iphone
like that that really
was disappointing too and that goes to
my other complaint about this film is
where are the memorable moments here
like where are those scenes that are
gonna stick with me and that i'll think
about forever i don't think there was
one for me the only scene that i thought
was amazing in this film
was
the car chase with penguin and i'm not
even a big car chase type of scene fan
right that's usually my least favorite
type of scene but i thought it was
amazing how it was shot and
i love the last shot obviously where
it's from the penguins perspective and
we're seeing batman walk towards him but
that's another complaint about the film
was this was a movie that the two
trailers
you know somehow it spoiled so much even
for a long movie and
why is i think the stuff they picked for
the trailers was the best stuff from the
film but it's more important that the
stuff they picked from the trailers was
huge story beats that took away suspense
like you know when he goes to
the funeral and you know a car is going
to come through there from the riddler
because we see it in the trailer same
thing the best shot of the film was in
the trailers with the penguin seeing him
upside down there's many moments like
that again that were just ruined by the
trailer and then people hyped up the
first 20 minutes of the film it felt
like that was the whole trailer and
the same song they use in the trailer
they use in the movie twice where that's
where it gets gimmicky and it's like how
many times we have to hear the same
nirvana song i i just don't like that
and you know what it all felt mushed
together because of this that there
wasn't those big set pieces now yes you
know dc detective comics it really was
batman the detective but i think i got
obsessed with that right and that we
didn't get enough of maybe just bruce
wayne or
having more big action moments and i
didn't even think the action was that
amazing and you know what
again another scene we saw in the
trailer and it's literally just as long
as when he does that effect where it's
really awesome where batman's fighting
those guys
pushers in the orphanage and
all the lights go out and you see all
the gunfire but matt reeves he's just
repeating a beat he did in war the
planet of the apes
exactly
exactly the same scene actually you'd
replace us
this frame the same the same lighting
it's like come on like that's so soon
for that for me and it's just like this
is the batman you're doing there should
be more clever action scenes for this
now i liked robert patterson as batman
you know i like that he was a broken
batman and you know what i really liked
the narration he was doing and the way
it set up that that was the beginning of
the movie
i thought we were gonna get that the
whole movie and i actually would have
liked that i think that would have
really worked i was in for that that
felt different in eu for batman and
gotten to us in his broken mindset and
then we don't go back to that till the
end so it felt disconnected there with
being in the mindset of bruce wayne and
i do think it worked well in good
writing is having your villain and your
protagonist totally lined up here and
that they connect on many levels and
that the batman is seeing things
ridler's doing and not necessarily
disagreeing with his you know beliefs in
these things just how he's going about
at the riddler so they did a good job
with that and i just think that
we look at the performances though of
let's say zoe kravitz who i'm also a big
fan of from big little lies especially
but her playing catwoman
i don't know
it just felt just a safe performance
like i thought it was good and i still
didn't even think that were robert
patterson's performance that was good
but i hate to say but it there's points
where it does feel a little one note for
both of them um that you almost want a
little more dynamic acting hero just
something different and it just doesn't
contribute to the whole
boring feel of this this film but yes i
see that they wanted to be grounded in
reality and really grounded but
i mean it just became too much crime
jargon at points and it just i started
zoning out you know and
i don't know i just didn't think that it
was the most engaging script i think the
script really hurt it and it could have
been way more interesting and had you
sucked in especially again for this long
run time and i do think it was
predictable i don't think there was
these big riddler twists revealed i mean
you could see that riddler was an orphan
as well that was combing a mile away and
that was going to relate to thomas wayne
so it didn't really have that many
shocking things and then them alluding
out to a new joker i hope they don't do
a joker for the sequel again like enough
with the joker there's so many good
batman villains do we really need him
again it's too much just please i
thought it was two-face at first i
thought that'd be way cooler um and i'm
still crossing fingers for mr freeze to
come back in a version like this because
he's my favorite but overall i would
give this film a 7.9 what i will say i
do think it's better than the dark
knight rises i think it's nowhere near
the dark knight so people saying it's
better than the dark knight have recency
bias for sure and
i think batman begins is better too so
i think it's better than the zac snyder
batman projects and a lot of the older
batman's but again i think it's going to
be ultimately something people don't
really remember i think it's forgettable
and i think there's a cool version of
gotham here i think that i love the look
of gotham i do like what they're doing
with the batman himself
but it's not as original as it thinks
this film there wasn't moments where i
was just like yeah i've seen all this
before like there wasn't things that
just stuck with me that felt fresh and
different um that i'll keep with me so
i've given a 7.9 that was pretty good
and i know i put a lot of criticism in
this but
i wanted to play the things that just
made me feel like it had the pieces here
to be amazing and
these things that hurt it for me just
brought it down to okay you know so i'm
giving a 7.9 let me know what you guys
think
did you like this batman where would you
rank in other batman films and share all
your thoughts i read every comment and
try to respond as many as i can and
please make sure to subscribe so much
one of my movie reviews i also do
celebrity interviews as well and tv
reviews and please follow me at steve
barley show on twitter instagram and
tick tock for more of me and i'll see
you next time